اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ساعتين اخباريه
جديده نخصص معظمها لتغطيه المشهد بالسودان
بدايتها بالعناوين
اشتباكات متقطعه في الخرطوم ونقابه اطباء
السودان تعلن ارتفاع عدد القتل المدنيين
الى 425
الدعم السريع يتحدث عن هجوم وشيك للجيش في
حلفايه وام درمان وجنوب الخرطوم
اجلاء اكثر من ثمانيه الاف شخص عبر ميناء
حتى الان
في ساعاتنا الاخباريه ايضا
تعلن سيطرتها على طريق امداد رئيسيه
بباخمت وموسكو تقصف موقعا للمسيره قرب
خرسون
[موسيقى]
وقبل بدايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه نعيد
التذكير بالاخبار العاجله قبل قليل وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
يستقبل مبعوث مجلس
السياده السوداني واكد ايضا وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه على دعوه المملكه للتهدئه في
السودان وتغليف المصلحه الوطنيه وزير
الخارجيه السعودي كذلك اكد على ضروره وقف
كل اشكال التصعيد العسكري في السودان في
السودان ايضا ورغم الهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه لا تزال الاشتباكات مستمره حيث
تجددت في ولايات سودانيه من بينها محيط
القياده العامه والخرطوم بحري فيما تبادل
الجيش والدعم السريع الاتهامات مجددا بشان
انتهاك الهدنه المعلنه ياتي ذلك فيما
تتفاقم الاوضاع الطبيه حيث دعا الهلال
الاحمر السوداني المنظمات الدوليه بتقديم
مساعداتها العاجله
فيما يخص الوضع ايضا كذلك الصحي في
السودان اعلنت نقابه الاطباء ارتفاع عدد
القتلى المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات الى 425
شخصا واصابه 2000 و91 شخصا واشارت النقابه
ايضا الى ان 16 الى ان سته عشر مستشفى
تعرضت للقصف منذ بدايه المواجهات حيث طالت
عمليات القصف مستشفى البراحه في الخرطوم
بحري يوم امس
الان الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
يؤكد في التصريحاته على الموقف المصري
بضروره الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار في
السودان اذن السيسي يقول بان مصر تؤكد
ضروره الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار في
السودان اذا اكد المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال
الاحمر السوداني ان العمل داخل المستشفيات
يجري بامكانيات محدوده جدا وان هناك حاجه
ماسه لوصول المساعدات من الخارج لتجاوز
الاوضاع التي باتت مترديه
المؤسسات بتدبر يعني الوضع الذاتي وببعض
المساعدات من بعض الجهات حتى المنظمات بما
موجود عندها من مخزون ثابت ومنظم المنظمات
بما فيها حتى الهلال الاحمر السوداني
وغيرها كل المنظمات المعنيه بمساعده
لمساعدات الانسانيه وبتعمل في القطاع
الصحي كوضع طبيعي كجانب جوانب العمل
الانساني بكليه مخزون طبيعي لكن مخزون
الحالات العاديه للحالات الطارئه في الوضع
العاليه
فدلوقتي بتدبر اضافه الى
مساهمات
الاطباء لتشكيلاتهم المختلفه بهيئات
بنقابات
بتنظيمهم الحالي لمجابهه الواقع الناس
بتتبر عن
الخاص وكده لكن عشان نبدا نجابها الموجوده
دي لازم تيجي مساعدات من الخارج
وفيما تتفاقم ازمه نقص الادويه في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بعد مرور اسبوعين على
الاشتباكات الجاريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع حذر تجمع الصيادله المهنيين
بالسودان من كارثه صحيه بسبب عمليات نهب
للصيدليات وشركات ومخازن الادويه في مدن
العاصمه الثلاث بالتزامن مع اغلاق عدد
كبير من الصيدليات في ام درمان منذ اندلاع
الاشتباكات حاليا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديلناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت اكبر
بالاضافه للفوط الصحيه
للسيدات تكاد تكون الان ما موجوده خالص
كمان مشكله الالبان عند الاطفال دي مشكله
كارثه حقيقيه الان الالبان غير موجوده
وجدت الاحداث الدواء
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او اذا تفتشوا ما خلى
اي حته فتش عشان تقول
خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حتى ما
لقينا
مع دخول المعارك بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اسبوعها الثالث تجددت الاشتباكات
حيث تشهد منطقتا المهندسين والصالحه
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله وقصفا
بالطيران بحسب مراسل العربيه وبحسب شهود
عيان من الحلفاء مدينه الخرطوم بحري بدا
الجيش في نشر وحداته والقيام بعمليات
تمشيط بعد معارك عنيفه شاهدتها المنطقه
هذا وتجدد سماع دوي انفجارات واصوات اطلاق
النار في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
وفي الاثناء كان الجيش هو مواصله اجلاء
رعايه الدول الاجنبيه من قاعده وادي سيدنا
الجويه دون تهديدات مع استمرار المواجهات
المسلحه مع قوات الدعم السريع قبل ذلك
اوقفت كل من مصر وامريكا وبريطانيا عمليات
اجلاء المواطنين من مطار وادي سيدنا
لاسباب امنيه وحتى وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
في بيان لها الموجودين في القاعده على
مغادرتها في اقرب فرصه متاحه كما حذرت
السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم مواطنيها من
التوجه لمطاري وادي سيدنا بسبب تصاعد
التهديد الامني والعنف في المطار ومحيطه
وحول عمليات الاجراء المستمره من السودان
يستمر الجسر الجوي في تنفيذ خطته في اجلاء
الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه نحو قاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه في مدينه جده هذا وقد
وصلت اليوم الى القاعده طائره عسكريه
تابعه للقوات الجويه السعوديه حيث افاد
مراسل العربيه بان طائره سعوديه اجلت 82
شخصا بينهم خمسه واربعون سعوديا من
بورتسودان الى ميناء جده
من ميناء جده او من جده ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه هاني نصفيان هاني مرحبا بك معي في
هذه الساعه كيف تجري امور الاجلاء في جده
حتى هذه اللحظه ان كان من معلومات جديده
او ارقام لديك
نعم نايف اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا عمليات الاجلاء مستمره سواء
عبر الجسر الجوي او كذلك عبر الاسطول
البحري نتحدث هناك في ميناء جده الاسلامي
وكذلك قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه تحديدا
نتحدث عن سفن تجاريه وكذلك سفن عسكريه
اجنبيه الى جانب مشاركه ايضا وسفن القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه التي تقوم
باجلاء الرعايه من بورسودان الى كذلك جده
وايضا نتحدث عن تامينها بالممرات المائيه
التي تنقل هؤلاء الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه
اذا لدينا في هذه الاحصائيات التي قامت او
قامت بها او قام بها الاسطول البحري سواء
عبر القوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه او كذلك عبر الفرقاطات العسكريه
الاجنبيه وايضا السفن التجاريه تتجاوز
خلال اسبوع
ما يزيد عن 23 سفينه قامت بنقل رعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه حتى هذا اليوم هنا تحديدا
في قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وما يقوم
به ايضا من عمليات اجلاء سواء عبر القوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه التي تقود وتشرف
على مهام اجراء الرعايه هنا جوا وكذلك
الطائرات العسكريه الاخرى الاجنبيه او
كذلك التجاريه فقد وصلت حتى هذا اليوم 47
نفذت حتى هذا اليوم 47 رحله جويه سواء
القادمه او كذلك المغادره وعندما نتحدث عن
القادمه فهي تقوم باجلاء الرعايه من بورت
سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل او قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه وايضا هناك مشاركه
من طائرات عسكريه اجنبيه وتجاريه تقوم
باجراء هؤلاء الرعايه وايضا لا ينطبق
الامر ايضا عند مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم طبعا
سوف نتحدث عن نقطه تحدثت عنها في البدايه
وهي وهو مطار وادي سعيد
هذا المطار تحديدا هو مطار كما تحدثت انه
فعلا ما زال
هناك معلومات انه غير امن ولكن الطائرات
الاجنبيه العسكريه وكما ايضا طائرات
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه تقوم بنقل
الرعايه من هذا المطر الا ان هذا المطار
تحديدا يفتقد للمواصفات الخاصه كمطار
يهبط فيه او تهبط فيه الطائرات بعدم وجود
المارشال او ايضا المراقب الجوي وعدم ايضا
وجود الامكانيات المتوفره لنزول هذه
الطائرات ولكن بخبره هؤلاء الطيارين فهم
يقومون اضطراريا لنزول الى هذا من اجل
اجلاء الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه نتحدث
اليوم ما تم اجلائه ونقله من السودان الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه اعداد وصلت
الى
2123 راكبا وصلوا بسلام وامان طيب هاني
اريد ان اسال ايضا كذلك عن الاجراءات التي
يتم اتخاذها في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه
للطائرات القادمه من مطار وادي سيدنا او
ايضا حتى من بورتودان
نعم وادي سيدنا او كذلك برج سودان هناك
اولا
يعني يختلفان في موضوع المطارين خاصه في
الاجراءات الامنيه وكذلك ايضا التهديدات
المحتمله وكذلك ايضا
مطار ايضا يصلح للهبوط ام لا
جميعهما حاليا يصلح ولاكن الاقرب بورت
سودان هو قد يكون الافضل والمناسب الا ان
وجود رعايه في وادي سيدنا قد يكون ايضا
نزول هذه الطائرات اضراريا لنقل هؤلاء
الرعايه عموما الطائرات التي تهبط على
هذين المطاريين هي طائرات عسكريه
تنقل الرعايه و تصلهم الى هذا المدرج والى
هذه القاعده التي نشاهدها طبعا في انتظار
ايضا في اللحظات او الساعه القادمه وصول
طائره عسكريه هنديه سوف تنقل قرابه 140
شخصا من رعايه الهند هم قادمون الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه ليتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم بسلام وامان هناك اولا تبدا
عمليه فحص او فحص الركاب وايضا خلوهم من
التاكد من علاماتهم الصحيه وبعد ذلك يتم
منحهم التاشيرات الطارئه حتى يتم مغادره
الى بلادهم هذه الطائره والطائرات ايضا
حتى القدم الى هذه القاعده قاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه شكرا جزيلا لك من جده
مراسل العربيه نصفيان على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
الجيش السوداني استمرار قوات الدعم السريع
فانتهاك الهدنه المعلنه من خلال عمليات
تحشيد تقوم بها غرب العاصمه الخرطوم الجيش
دان استمرار القصف العشوائي وعمليات النهب
للممتلكات بما فيها البنوك ومنازل
المواطنين وقال بيان للجيش ان قوات الدعم
السريع حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى تكنه
ومركز قياده لعملياتها البيان اكد ايضا
على استمرار الجيش في تهيئه الظروف
المناسبه لنزول الشرطه تدريجيا الى
الشوارع
[موسيقى]
قوات الدعم السريعه تهمت هي الاخرى الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائرات بين الدعم
السريع اشار الى ان طائرات الجيش ما تزال
تحلق في سماء الخرطوم وتنتهك الهدنه الدعم
السريع قال ان الجيش يستعد لشن هجوم في
العاصمه الخرطوم ومدينه الحلفايه وام
درمان وبحري
هذا وشهدت الخرطوم نظارات جويه واطلاق نار
متبادل بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مع
دخول المعارك اسبوعها الثالث
اسبوع ثالث من القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرفات صراع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرر المواجهه بالسلاح وتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفارينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظرف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك معي في هذه
الساعه اريد السؤال عن الاوضاع الحاليه في
الخرطوم الحديث عن طلعات لطيران الجيش
الحديث ايضا كذلك عن اشتباكات منذ صباح
اليوم في عدد من المواقع في العاصمه
مرحبا نايف كان هذا صباح اليوم بالفعل في
صبيحه هذا اليوم لكن الان وفي الثلاث
ساعات الماضيه هناك هدوء نسبي وهناك حركه
للمواطنين واضحه كذلك ليست طبيعيه بالكامل
لكنها شبه طبيعيه في مناطق متفرقه وايضا
بدات او بدا المواطنين للخروج لقضاء
احتياجياتهم منذ ان هدات هذه الاحوال في
الصباح اليوم ايضا سمعنا بعض اطلاق الرصاص
وكذلك دليل المدافع منذ الصباح لكن بعد
ذلك هدات هذه الاوضاع نسبيا والان كما
تشاهد الوضع شبه طبيعي هنا في العاصمه
الخرطوم وفي شرقيها بالتحديد في بقيه
المناطق تجددت الاشتباكات في مناطق محدوده
هي منطقه الفتيحاب ايضا محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون سمعت اصوات للرصاص وكذلك في
منطقه الصالحه جنوب غرب ام درمان ربما هذه
الابرز في النقاط التي تجددت فيها
الاشتباكات بالنسبه للحركه لحركه تبدو شبه
طبيعيه هناك محل تجاريه بدات العمل بالفعل
في هذه المنطقه وكذلك افران الخبز ايضا من
هنا من غير بعيد من هذه المنطقه شاهدنا
واحده من المحطات التي كانت تشهد وصول
النازحين الذين يريدون الخروج من ولايه
الخرطوم الى ولايات مختلفه كانت هذه
المحطه دائما مزدحمه يبحث فيها الركاب عن
الحافلات للخروج من الولايه في الولايات
الشرقيه والجنوبيه اليوم ايضا شهدت عدم
اقبال واضح من المواطنين الحافلات موجوده
لكنها لا تجد ركابا ليخرجوا من الولايه
ربما لان هنالك هذا الهدوء دفع المواطنين
الى عدم الخروج من الولايه او ربما من
كانوا قد نوى الخروج من الولايه قد خرجوا
بالفعل وهل كان هناك تدفق كبير خلال
الايام الماضيه سالم حسب ما رصدت انت على
الارض
نعم كان هنالك تدفق كبير في هذه المناطق
او في هذه المحطات التي يخرج منها
المواطنين الى ولايات مجاوره كان تدفق
كبير جدا نشاهد اليوم هدوء في هذا الامر
او قله مقارنه بالايام الماضيه ايضا
التحسن اليوم في ان الامر يعني تدريجيا في
هذه الهدنه من هدنه الى هدنه هناك تدرج من
كل هدنه لاخرى بان هناك تحسن في الاوضاع
هناك يعني قله او فترات زمنيه قصيره
للاشتباكات نفسها كذلك الحركه باتت اقرب
الى الطبيعيه كل هذا التحسن ربما يدعو الى
التفاؤل في مساله ان الهدن او الهدنات
يزداد تحسنها يوما بعد اخر طيب فيما يخص
الوضع الانساني ايضا والصحي في العاصمه
الخرطوم كيف يمكن وصفه حتى هذه اللحظه
سهله
بالنسبه للوضع الانساني حقيقه الشكاوى من
المواطنين من تدفق المواد الغذائيه وتدفق
المحروقات كذلك بالنسبه لمحطات الوقود هذه
واحده من الشكاوى يضاف اليها الشكاوى
الامنيه او المشكله الامنيه وهي مشكله
واضحه ومعروفه خاصه بعد عمليات النهب
والسرقات كانت الشرطه السودانيه بالامس قد
اعلنتها واوضحت ان قوات الاحتياط المركزي
ستبدا عملها في تامين الممتلكات
والمواطنين بعد ذلك جاء بيان الجيش محدثا
عن هذه يتحدث عن هذه النقطه نقطه الشرطه
وان هذه العمليات ستكون بالتدريج بالنسبه
لنزول الشرطه للشوارع لكن بالنسبه
للعمليات الانسانيه يحتاج المواطنون فيما
يتعلق بالمستشفيات الى مزيد من التامين
للكوادر الطبيه للوصول الى المستشفيات
وكذلك وصول الموده اللوجستيه او المعينات
اللازمه لعمل هذه المستشفيات المستشفيات
الخارجه عن العمل ايضا تحتاج الى مجهود
لان تعود الى العمل في حال الحاجه لها
خاصه موضوع الطوارئ والاصحابات وكذلك
الحالات التي تتعلق بغسيل الكلى وغيرها
وحتى العمليات كل هذه الامور تحتاج الى
مراجعات كبيره جدا في بالنسبه لما يتعلق
بالامور الطبيه الامور الاخرى المعينات
الغذائيه تحتاج ايضا الى تدفق كل هذا
الامر يرتبط بهدنه
تلتزم فيها الاطراف بمسارات امنه تستطيع
بعد ذلك المساعدات الانسانيه او حتى
المعينات اللوجستيه بالوصول الى مناطق
السكر ماذا عن توفر هذه المعينات حاليا
اتحدث عن
الادويه في المقام الاول عن الغذاء ايضا
كذلك عن مياه الشرب ايضا
سالم والتي يعني دار الكثير من الحديث
حولها وربما مقاطع الفيديو التي سربت لبيع
اساسا المياه غير الصالحه للشرب باسعار
كبيره جدا
مشكله مياه الشوربه اكبر مدينه تعاني منها
هي مدينه بحري لان احياء كثيره جدا من
مدينه بحري تعاني من قطاع تام لمياه الشرب
منذ بدا هذه الازمه دخلنا في اسبوعين
الثالثه الان حتى هذه اللحظه ولا قطره ماء
واحده في احياء كثيره جدا من مدينه بحري
وهذا من الامور المؤسفه تلتحق بها بعد ذلك
حيث صالحه وهو في ام درمان في اقصى جنوب
ام درمان بعد ذلك بعض الاحيان في ام درمان
وبعض الاحياء في الخرطوم وفي وسط الخرطوم
كذلك مشكله المياه مشكله
بالفعل هي
مزعجه ومقلقه كذلك لان ابعادها كذلك في
عدم شرب المياه النقيه بعد ذلك الى امراض
الى غير ذلك مما حذرت منه منظمه الصحه
العالميه في احد بياناتها لكن المهمه الان
هو ان يتم تدارك هذا الامر بالرجوع هذه
المحطات للعمل وما زال المواطنين يطالبون
بذلك كانت ولايه الخرطوم قبل اسبوع او
اكثر قد وعدت باصلاح محطات المياه لكنها
بعد ذلك قالت انه يحتاج وتفاصيل كثيره
تتعلق بهذا الامر اما فيما يتعلق
بالمعينات الغذائيه كل هذا الامر يرتبط
بفتح الطرق اولا ووصول هذه المساعدات لانه
غالبيه الجسور الان خارج الخدمه عدا جسور
محدوده جدا التي يستطيع ان يمر بها
المواطلون يضاف الى ذلك ان العديد من هذه
الطرق يتعرض فيها المواطنون لمضايقات من
القوات المنتشره والتي تحمل انواع من
الاسلحه الكثيره جدا كل هذه الامور مرتبطه
مع بعضها البعض من الخرطوم راسله العربيه
سالم الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغ هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليات نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد حاليا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديل الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شحو الان المشكله بقت اكبر
تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار والصغار
على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه بارتفاع مستمر
فيما اصنافها المتوفره بانخفاض مقلق وجد
الاحداث الدوحه
انسولين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او لذاته
ما خلينا حته ما لقينا وحتى عربيه ذاته
يتحركوا بها عشان يجيبوا لي الدواء ما في
بنزين ما في هناك طريقه نمرق من البلد
عشان نمشي نفتش الدواء نجيبه اما بالنسبه
للمستشفيات فلا يزال القليل منها الذي
يعمل في الخرطوم يعاني نقصا حادا في
الادويه والمستلزمات العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه
المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
اكدت شرطه سودانيه ان قوات الاحتياطي
المركزي فصيل تابع لها وتم الدفع به الى
الشوارع لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين وشددت على ان من يقودها خرجوا
كليه الشرطه والقانون وقالت الشرطه ردا
على الدعم السريع في البيان انه لا وجود
للامن الشعبي في قوات الاحتياط المركزي
مؤكده بان مقر البنك المركزي لم يتعرض لاي
هجوم وان الحريق الذي تم الاعلان عنه يعود
لاحد فروع البنك
في الاثناء قال المتحدث الرسمي لقوه
الحريه والتغيير للعربيه ان القوى
السياسيه تتواصل مع اطراف دوليه واطراف
عسكريه في الداخل للتفاوض والوصول الى حل
للازمه
لانه نحن على تواصل برضو مع مع اطراف
دوليه ومع بعض الاطراف من العسكريين في
الداخل
للنقاش معهم حول يعني ما يمكن ان يتم من
تفاوض لانهاء هذه الازمه بالتالي هم ابدو
الموافقه وهذا معلوم بالتالي نعتقد انه
الام ما يدور لطالما انه الطرفين وافقوا
على الحوار يبقى استمرار المعارك واضح انه
هو لتحسين الموقف على الارض
[موسيقى]
حاليا الادويه
اللي خلصت عندنا تماما او على وشك يا
ادويه الضغط
[موسيقى]
وجدت الاحداث الدوحه
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها
[موسيقى]
وعلى خلفيه المواجهات المسلحه المستمره
بدا موظفون في ولايه الخرطوم عطله رسميه
حتى اشعار اخر وذلك بسبب الظروف الامنيه
التي تعيشها البلاد ولا تشمل العطله غرف
اداره الازمه والمرافق الخدميه الحيويه
حذر رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوك من ان النزاع في السودان قد
يتفاقم الى احدى اسوا الحروب الاهليه في
العالم حاله لم يتم وضوح واعتبر ان ذلك
سيشكل كابوسا للعالم وستكون له تداعيات
كبيره وراى حمدوك النزاع الحالي هو عباره
عن حرب لا معنى لها مؤكدا ان لا احد سيخرج
منها منتصرا
معنا من الخرطوم اللواء بابا بكر ابراهيم
احمد الخبير العسكري واللواء السابق في
القوات الجويه ومن القاهره الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
صلاح قريب مرحبا بكم معي في هذه الساعه
ابدا معك استاذ خليل من القاهره الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي كان قبل قليل قد
اكد على ضروره الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار
في السودان وكذلك اكد على اهميه امتناع
طرف خارجي عن التدخل في الازمه بالسودان
كيف تقرا مجمل هذه التصريحات للرئيس
المصري اولا
استاذ صلاح هل تسمعني
سيد صلاح
كعاده السؤال مره اخرى كنت اسال قبل قليل
عن مصنع سؤالك جيدا طيب اهلا بك مجددا معي
كنت اسال عن تصريحات الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي فيما يخص السودان قال بان
مصر تؤكد ضروره الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار
في السودان هذا اولا واكد على اهميه
امتناع اي طرف خارجي عن التدخل في الازمه
بالسودان كيف تقرا هذه التصريحات
نعم الموقف المصري من بدايه الازمه كان
واضحا حتى عندما قام
باجتماع طارئ للمندوبين الدائمين الى
جامعه الدول العربيه بان الازمه الداخليه
في السودان هي ازمه انسانيه ازمه سودانيه
سودانيه ويجب ان يتم حلها في اطار
السوداني السوداني ايضا
اشاره القاهره بان اي تدخل خارجي في
الازمه السودانيه سوف سوف يفاقم من هذه
الازمه وربما يؤدي الى انزلاق السودان الى
فوضى فبالتالي الرؤيه المصريه او دائما
نسميها الموقف المصري موقف صريح جدا
الموقف الموقف المصري الطقس موقف ان يكون
الجميع الفاعلين او الجميع الفوائد
الاقليميه والدوليه في الازمه يجب عليها
ان تكون محايده ولا تتدخل في هذه الازمه
لانها ازمه سودانيه سودانيه فبالتالي يجب
ان تكون في اطار الحله السوداني جانب اخر
ايضا القاهره يعني قامت بالاديد من
الثوابت الطارقيه في ظل الانسانيه
السودانيه ايضا كما تعلم جيدا من القاهره
ساكثر الدول المجاوره التي سمحت للعديد من
السودانيين بالدخول اراضيها حتى ليس فقط
السودانيين ايضا عندما قامت من ريان الدول
الاجنبيه فبالتالي القاهره تقف موقف ثابتا
اتجاه الازمه في بين طرفي الصلاه في
السودان فهي لا تريد ان تتدخل في هذه
الازمه وايضا لا تريد ان تكون لها دور في
اهميه تعجيج الصرافه وبالتالي الموقف
المصري الى موقف صريح وواضح من بدايه
الازمه
ايضا من الخرطوم اللواء ابو بكر ابراهيم
احمد ارحب بك معي مره اخرى في هذه الساعه
يعني ليس الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
فقط هو من طلب وقف كل اشكال التصعيد
العسكريه في السودان كذلك ايضا وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اسالك عن يعني مدى قبول هذه الدعوات من
طرفي الازمه اليوم في السودان بوقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري هل هي قريبه برايك
ام لازلنا في بدايه هذا الصراع
الوضع في الخرطوم
انا لا اتوقف مع قبول احد الطرفين
[موسيقى]
القوات الدعم السريع الان محاصره داخل
الخرطوم
وهي التواصل دعم قواتها داخل الخرطوم قبل
ثلاثه يوم
جمعت عدد من العربات واغذر ب 150 من
الاقاليم ودفعت بهم قبل الخرطوم بضروره
القوات الحكوميه لازم تشتبك مع هذه
دمرت هذه العربات فدفعوا مره اخرى
208 عربيه ودمرت
فالقوات الدعم السريع
تناضل لكي تدعم الخرطوم بمقاتلين رغم
تدميرهم ومستمر وقوات القوات المسلحه
تشتبك مع هذه الاطراف على مدار الساعه
في ايام الهدره حتى في ايام الهدنه
الماضيه يعني كان هناك تصاعد كبير في
الاشتباكات بين
الطرفين الى الى ماذا يمكن ان نعزوه لوابا
بكر
السبب يعني هذه قوات الداخله داخله داخل
الخرطوم اما داخل الخرطوم قوه الدعم
السريع هناني تجهيز يربط بين
شرق النيل غرب النيل توجد قاعده وادي
سيدنا في غرب النيل بالامس ليلا حاولت
قوات الدعم والشيع السيطره على هذه الجسم
لكي تدفع بقوات للاستيلاء على قاعده وادي
سيدنا
نوايا جانبين
تؤكد ان هنالك تسقيط على الارض
على على الجانب الاخر القوات الحكوميه قبل
36 ساعه انزلت
الكرت الامر انزلت حوالي 10 فرق هذا يعادل
20000 من القوات
المشاه وتسحبها دبابات
لتامين الارض بالنسبه للمواطنين كما ذكرها
تقريركم ان المواطن وان واحد منهم مشكلتنا
الاساسيه هي معاناه المعاناه من المياه من
الكهرباء من الادويه من الاغذيه وكل يوم
اذا حتى ان احنا نسمع وقت اطلاق النا يعني
بيفكر سيكون غدا لان كل هذه
الامدادات في تناقص امنيتنا
ان القتال لكن واضح جدا ان كل من الطرفين
يريد ان يحسم القتال لصالحه ولذلك انا ارى
ان
هناك مؤشرات تدل على
غرف نهايه المعركه
توجد الان
القوات الدعم السريع
القوات المسلحه
استوللت على العربات موجوده من غير مغفلين
بتفتيش وجدوا انه الوقود نفس
وكذلك
باستجواب بعض الاسرى وجدوا ان بعض الاسئله
تم تجميله في داخل الخرطوم
وعمره في العسكريه ثلاثه ايام فقط فكل
هذه
لا يمكن لا يمكن اطلاقا ان يصمت وقت اطلاق
النار في ظل امنيات كل من الطرفين لحسم
المعركه
طيب استاذ صلاح يعني كما ذكر اللوابا بكر
هناك تصعيد كبير على الارض
وتحشيد ايضا حتى في العاصمه الخرطوم هذا
كله يتزامن مع ما ذكره المبعوث الخاص
للامير العام للامم المتحده في السودان
السيد فولكر بريتس
بان الاطراف اقتربت من الجلوس على طاوله
الحوار فهل ما يحدث من تصعيد اليوم هو
مؤشر فعلا حقيقي لان هذه الاطراف تجتمع
وما يحدث اليوم هو محاوله لكسب
الكثير من المواقع المهمه او السيطره او
حتى ايضا اوراق يعني ميدانيه وعسكريه
لتكون على طاوله المفاوضات تشكل قوه لاي
من الطرفين
لا اعتقد ذلك الاسبوع الثالث هنالك
متغيرات على المستوى الميداني وايضا على
مستوى
الرايه العامه الشعب السوداني اصبحت
القضيه قضيه رائعه سوداني راينا بالعديد
من السوشيال ميديا وهي دامان ومحتوى قدمته
الحكومه السودانيه بعدم انقطاع شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي العديد من النشطات سواء
كان ابر الفيسبوك تويتر قبل جميع المنصات
السوشيال ميديا قدموا افادات كبيره جدا
بان القضيه هي ليست قضيه الجيش السوداني
لوحده بل اصبحت قضيه رائعه سوداني وايضا
يعني طالب جميع السودانيين بان لا تفاوض
مع ميليشيات استباهت ارتكبت جرائم ضد
القانون الانساني فبالتالي القضيه هي ليست
قضيه الجيش ان يتحاور مع ميليشيات لكن
ايضا هي قضيه الرايه العامه السوداني هو
الذي يحدد من سكان هنالك حوار ام لا
فاصبحت اذا هنالك طرف سالي دخل الازمه اذا
الراي العام السوداني جزء لا يتجزا من
عمليه المشهد السياسي هنالك راينا بالامس
يعني بالكثير من الشخصيات دعنا ان هناك من
يقول بان المشهد السوداني اليوم يحتاج الى
هدنه يحتاج الى تثبيت هذه الهدنه بسبب
الاوضاع الانسانيه على كل الاصعده
المترديه في العاصمه الخرطوم فحتى جلوس
هذه الاطراف على طاوله حوار امميه سيكون
هدفها الاول هو الهدنه وربما تثبيت الهدنه
بين الطرفين وبعد ذلك بحث كل المسائل
الخلافيه بين طرفي هذه الازمه سيد صلاح
اذا كنت تتفق
الهدنه من يقترقه هو الضعيف فيما يتعلق
بجانب الانساني
هو مؤشر كبير جدا الى الدور الدول الغربيه
في في الازمه السودانيه اذا راينا وجهات
نظر مختلفه كيف قامت تلك الدول بجار اياها
من عبر طائرات او ابر سفن وهي تعلم جيدا
ان هنالك ازمه انسانيه وصحيه في الخرطوم
فبالتالي كان من احرى لهذه الدول اذا كانت
لديها مصلحه في السودان
كانت قامت تلك الطائرات التي قامت باجراء
اياها وسفن بتحميلها بادويه وبالاديت من
المواد او البان الاطفال للشعب السوداني
ولكن الفوائد او الدول الغربيه لا يهمها
الشعب السوداني هي هبه هي فقط تراقب
الموقفا انكسر ثقيل في النهايه من سينتصر
سوف تكون معه اذا هنالك لعبه كبيره هي
لعبه المحاور او الدول الغربيه في الازمه
السودانيه اذا نحن نتكلم عن الازمه
العمليات التفاوض هي ليست منا الحل
السياسي اصبحت القضيه ليست بين فريقين او
قوتين السرطان اصبحت قضيه راي ام سوداني
واذا رايت بس للامس فقط وقبيه وبعديه
لوجدت كميات هائله جدا من الفيديوهات ومن
ميديا تتحدث ان اذا كان هنالك اي سوداني
يجب ان يقاتل من اجل اي سوداني وطني حريصه
لسنوات بلده يجب عليه حمل السيلاوي الدفاع
مع الجيش السوداني لانه الجيش السوداني
يمصر رمز للدوله السودانيه وايضا اتحمد
ميليشيات الدائمه انها تقدم مشروع لتشكيل
الاقليم ككل وايضا انتقلت الدور الكبير
لدائميه بان الذين يدعمونه لا يدركون قطر
هذا المشروع الذي سوف
يقسم السودان الى دويلات ضعيفه تكون تعبئه
وتتحكم فيها القوه الاقليميه والدوليه طيب
ابقى معي سيد صلاح وكذلك لواء بكر سعود
اليكما في ثنايا هذه الساعه اذا افادت
رئيسه العمليات الميدانيه
لليونيسف جل لول ر بان الوضع في السودان
لا يساعد العاملين في المجال الانساني
بايصال الخدمات الى المحتاجين مؤكده ان
بعض العاملين تعرضوا للهجوم
القصف والصراع وانعدام الامن في البلاد لا
تساعد العاملين في المجال الانساني بايصال
الخدمات الى المحتاجين لقد تعرض بعض
العاملين في المجال الانساني للهجوم
بالاضافه الى من لقي حتفه في الطريق الوضع
في غايه الصعوبه
واضافت رئيسه العمليات الميدانيه لليونيسف
في السودان جل لولر في بيان الله ان
اليونيسف على درايه بان هناك اكثر من 15
مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
مؤكده ان الوضع الحالي الذي يشهده السودان
من قصف وهجمات سيكون في تزايد
برا
يه ان قبل حدوث ازمه السودان الحاليه هناك
اكثر من 15 مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه من بينهم ثمانيه ملايين طفل وان
القصف الجوي والهجمات على البنيه التحتيه
للمياه وتدمير اللقاحات الحيويه التي
تشهدها البلاد ستكون في ارتفاع ملحوظ
استقبل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان المبعوث الخاص لرئيسي مجلس
السياده الانتقال السوداني السفير دفع
الله الحاج علي وجرى خلال اللقاء بحث
الاوضاع الراهنه في السودان واكد وزير
الخارجي على دعوه السعوديه للتهدئه وتغليف
المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف كافه اشكال التصعيد
العسكري بما يحافظ على مقدرات ومكتسبات
السوداني وشعبه
وعلى وقع استمرار الاشتباكات وغياب اي
بوادر لحل قريب وصف برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي الوضع الانسانيه في السودان
بالكارتي
شوارع الخرطوم شبه خاليه لا امن ولا امان
اما اسواقها يكبل الكساد ايدي التجار فيها
فالمعروض قليل والطلب شبه معدوم
قالت
ان شاء الله
اقتصاد السودان صعد على سكه خسائر لا يمكن
تصور ابعادها وبات شبح المجاعه يهدد كل من
تقطعت بهم سبل الخروج منه برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي وصف الوضع الانساني في البلاد
بالكارثي مؤكدا انه يجب ان يتوقف القتال
اولا لتمكين ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
بامان
وضع انساني يزداد كل يوم سوءا وتحيط به
مخاوف من ارتفاع جنني في اسعار المواد
الغذائيه والوقود معنى فادي الاموال
والامدادات الاساسيه وتعطل الانظمه
المصرفيه
خضار واللحمه في عدن يعني ما
حالهم بات غايه في السوق والتردي واصعب
مهامهم تامين قوتهم اليومي وحاجاتهم
الغذائيه حيث شهدت اسعار السلع
الاستهلاكيه الضروريه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ارتفاعا كبيرا ومفاجئا مع اعتبره
السودانيون غير مبرر في حين عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار لظروف المواطنين
الصعبه
اندلاع الحرب جدد المخاوف من انزلاق
الاقتصاد السوداني نحو الانهيار الشامل
فمع دخول الحرب الاسبوع الثالث واستمرار
عمليات الاجلاء سترتفع احتمالات اصابه
النشاط الاقتصادي بالشلل وستنجر البلاد
نحو مصير مظلم واكبر خطرا
اياد حمود العربيه
اعود مره اخرى الى الضيوف في هذه الساعه
لواء بكر ابراهيم احمد الخبير العسكري
واللواء السابق في القوات الجويه ومن
القاهره في مركز الباحث في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه صلاح
خليل مرحبا بكم مجددا لوابا بكر اريد ان
اسال عن اهم التحولات العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه ايضا كذلك التي حدثت خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين برايك والتي يمكن
الحديث عنها كعناوين عسكريه رئيسيه في
السودان
خلال الاسبوع الفايد كانت استراتيجيه
الجيش تعتمد على استنزاف
وتدعم السريع داخل العاصمه
ليس هنالك اي قتال سوداني الا داخل
العاصمه وداخل العاصمه في المنطقه الخرطوم
منطقه ام درمان وبحري هادئه لذلك كان
استراتيجيه القوات المسلحه
القوات الدعم السريع من ناحيه الزخاير
قبل 36 ساعه رات القياده العامه المسلحه
ان الوقت قد حان
تمشيط المنطقه او الهجوم البري وقد بدات
المناوشات فعلا
واكون صريح معك كما قال محدثكم ولا ظاهره
الان الراي الشعب هو الذي يحدد
الشعب صحه والان راعي الغنم في السودان
يعلم تماما ان هنالك مؤامره
عالميه خارجيه دبرت السودان الدعم السريع
والجيش كانوا يعملون مع بعض لمده عشر
سنوات
وفي تناغم وقود حمدوك اتى بفوكلر وفوقلر
اتى بالايطاري
اتى بالحرب ولكي يؤمن فوكلر الايطالي
يستقطب حمايته
وزينوا له انه سيكون الحاكم للسودان الان
المؤامره انكسرت تماما 95% من المؤامره
انتهت في
تدمير قوات حماتي المتبقي داخل العاصمه
اذا سالت اي ما هي امنيتك امنيته ان يقضي
الجيش
والبوليس الاما تبقى من
فلول الدعم السريع هذه هي
معادله واضحه
والسودان كفر كفر
بالمجتمع الدولي مجتمع الدولي هو الذي انت
مشاكل العراق وسوريا واليمن
ولكن لحسن منه عبد الله
ابا بكر بان السودان ما انت صاعدت هذه
الازمه بين
طرفي الحرب الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
فسيزلق السودان ربما
ليصبح يعني نموذجا اشد قسوه من ليبيا او
سوريا او او اليمن ايضا حتى كذلك
يا اخي هذا الحمقوك هو الذي ادخل السودان
في هذه الورطه هو الذي دول
المشكله هو الذي اتى
بالامم المتحده من غير ان يشاور احد حتى
راس الدوله اتى
حاكم عامل السودان كبري
واعتمد على المليشيات
وزينوا له والان احرمه في دخلوه في محرقه
الان حتى الدعم السريع يعني يتاسف للدخوله
في هذه المعركه الغير متطابقه كل ما نريد
ان تنتهي هذه المعركه وان يبدا الحساب
الشعب السوداني سيبدا الحساب
تماما من هي الدول التي ساندت هذا العدوان
سواء كانت اقليميه او عالميه او امميه
سوف تنقل المعركه خلال اليومين القادمين
وتبدا عمليه الحساب
هذا الكلام واضح السود كلمته ولسه الجيش
ان يحيد عن هذا الغرار اشكرك شكر جزيل
اللواء ابو بكر ابراهيم احمد الخبير
العسكري واللواء السابق في القوات الجويه
نذكر مشاهدينا بجمله هذه الاخبار العاجله
اسفل الشاشه نقلا عن الخارجيه السعوديه
تؤكد اجلاء 45 من مواطني
من مواطنين السعوديه عبر طائره تابعه
للقوات الجويه من السودان الى جده للقوات
الجويه السعوديه طبعا الخارجيه السعوديه
اضافت ايضا بان اجمالي من تم اجلائهم من
السودان وصل الى
5,107 وتسعين شخص بينهم 184 سعوديا قالت
ايضا بان المملكه اجلت
513 شخصا ينتمون لمئه دوله من السودان اذا
الخارجيه السعوديه تؤكد بانها اجت 45 من
مواطنيها عبر طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه
السعوديه من السودان الى جده اكدت بان
اجمالي من تم اجلائهم من السودان حتى الان
وصل الى خمسه
الاف197 بينهم 184 سعوديا واكدت بانها
اجلت 513 شخصا ينتمون لمئه دوله من
السودان
ان الحكومه ما زالت مستقره
في مناطق خارجيه لدعم الوظيفه
كانت يعني هذه زياره يعني وجدت واسعه من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه ولعلها اك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واحده من الدول
التي تظلك التوسط بشان العمليه السياسيه
في السودان وهي جزء من الوساطه الرباعيه
وايضا مظله تعمل
على محاوله
الامور الى مجاريها كما كانت من فضلك
اكثر
الظروف يمكن ان يدعم
يدعم ذلك في تعديل خطا في الاصل كان غير
صحيح لانه ترفض الحوار في وقت كان الجيش
وافق فيه بشكل مبني في تعبير خطوه مهمه
خاصه
نقطه مهمه
من الضغوط على الخارجيه السودانيه يستجيب
كل المقومات الحكومه السودانيه تجاه وقت
الحرب وكذلك قوات الدعم دون ذلك بالتاكيد
سيكون المتضرر الاول والاخير هو الشعب
السودان طيب اليوم بالنظر الى الى الى ما
يحدث ميدانيا الى تصاعد الاشتباكات بين
طرفي هذه الازمه سواء في العاصمه الخرطوم
في الخرطوم بحري ام درمان عديد المناطق
ايضا كذلك في السودان تحليق حتى طيران
الجيش الاتهامات المتبادله بين طرفي هذه
الازمه وهناك يعني تصريحات او مؤشرات من
فولكر بيريتس بقرب يعني جلوس طرفي هذه
الازمه على طاوله الحوار ما الذي يمكن ان
نفهمه من كل هذه الحلقات سيد اشرف
تظل مستمره هنالك خروقات بالنسبه لكثير من
المبادرات التي دائما
والاخرى بسبب واحد رئيس
الاطراف النزاع كلها تريد تحقيق هدفها
وغايتها النهائيه من هذه الازمه فبالتالي
تصنع في موازنه الح هذا الهدف وتعتقد ان
المعرفه اصبحت محصوره في منطقه القصر
الجمهوري في محيط القياده العامه ومن
يتحقق له مثل الماهر
على هذه المنطقه هو يستطيع ان يفرضته هو
شروخه حتى ان كان هنالك تصور في هذه
المنطقه حتى ان كان هنالك
بشان هذه الحرب ونتيجه لذلك تجد ان دائما
هنالك هروبات مستمره بالنسبه للهدنه
وهذه اختراع عظيم في مساله تحديد وفوود
لان تكون ممثله لكل طرف
هو جدا في السعوديه وهذه خطوه مهمه وكافيه
من شانها ان تهدئ الكثير من النفوس وتشير
الى بدايه التفاوض الحريه
التي يتم خرجها هي مهمه واساسيه لانها
يعني في كثير من الاحيان تمكن المواطنين
وروى القضاء مع القليل من احتياجاتهم
وبالتالي يمكن ان تميز بوقف اطلاق النار
اشرف عبد العزيز
رئيس تحرير صحيفه الجريده انضم الينا من
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
جوله على ابرز الاخبار الدوليه في اخر
تطورات الاوضاع في مدينه باقمه حيث تدور
المعارك منذ اشهر قالها المتحدث باسم
القوات الاوكرانيه
شريفات ان بلا دوله لا تزال تسيطر على
الطريق امداد هام مؤذن الى المدينه مؤكدا
لوسائل الاعلام المحليه ان الوضع في باقمه
لا يزال صعبا بسبب محاولات القوات الروسيه
للسيطره على طريق الحياه المؤدي للمدينه
الا ان قوات بلاده ان تسمح للروس بقطع
الخدمات اللوجستيه للجيش الاوكراني
وفيما تستعد اوكرانيا لشن هجوم مضاد قال
متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات
موسكو قصفت موقع القياده والمراقبه
للطائرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه قرب منطقه
خرسون والحقت وحدات مدفعيه اضرارا
بنيرانها بموقع القياده والمراقبه ومركز
التحكم للطائرات دون الطيار التابعه للواء
124 من قوات الدفاع الاقليميه التابعه
لكيف مضيفا ان قوات موسكو دمرت مستودعه
تخزين الذخيره والمعدات قرب المدينه
الساحليه جنوب البلاد موضحا ان القصف
الروسيه اسفر عن مقتل 30 شخصا من صفوف
القوات الاوكرانيه وتدمير اكثر من عشر
مركبات قتاليه مصفحه
تعتزم كوريا الشماليه تعزيز الردع العسكري
ضد كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
منتقده اتفاق القمه الذي عقد هذا الاسبوع
بين البلدين بشان تعزيز الردع الموسع
الامريكي ووصفته بانه نتائج سياسه عدائيه
شائنه ضد بيونغيانج كانت واشنطن قد وافقت
على نشر غواصات مسلحه نوويا في كوريا
الجنوبيه واشراك سول في التخطيط النووي
لمواجهه التهديدات النوويه من جارتها
الشماليه
من جانبه تعهد الرئيس الاوكراني
بمحاسبه روسيا عقب سقوط عشرات القتلى
والجرحى جراء قصفها لمدينه اومان
الاوكرانيه
سنفعل كل ما هو ممكن لضمان محاسبه الدوله
الارهابيه على ما فعلته في اقرب وقت ممكن
اي شخص يعد لمثل هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه لا
يسعه الا ان يعرف انه سيصبح شريكا في
القتل وارهابيا ليس فقط اولئك الذين يعطون
الاوامر انتم جميعا ارهابيون وقتله وتجد
معاقبتكم جميعا
افادت وكاله بان الدول الاوروبيه باتت تضع
قيودا جديده على الصادرات والاستثمارات
الصينيه بسبب استيائها من علاقات بكين
الوثيقه مع الرئيس بوتين مشيره الى ان
دولا مثل المانيا وايطاليا تدرسان وضع
الضوابط التي اعتمدتها الولايات المتحده
على التصدير والاستثمار الاستهداف الصين
ووفقا للوكاله فان واشنطن والاتحاد
الاوروبي يعملان على تطوير ادوات جديده
لابطاء تقدم الصين في عده مجالات تشمل
اشباه الموصلات والدفاع مضيفه انهما
يناقشان وضع ضوابط على التصدير وتشديد
الرقابه على الاستثمارات وزياده التعاون
في مجال المواد الحيويه
قبل ايام من معاوده الكنيست عمله بعد عطله
تجددت الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل ضد مشروع
اصلاح النظام النظام القضائي الذي اقترحته
الحكومه برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو وتجمع بين
150 و200 الف شخص وابقى تقديرات وسائل
الاعلام المحليه
[موسيقى]
العميد لدين اتنسيات بيتها مش باطل يونس
اغلقت تركيا مجالها الجويه امام طائرات
شركه فلايوان ارمينيا دون سابق انذار حسب
ما ذكرت وكاله ارمين للانباء عن رئيس مجلس
اداره الشركه وقال ارام انانيان رئيس مجلس
اداره الشركه الارمنيه انه ولاسباب غير
مفهومه ودون ودون اي مبرر واضح الغت سلطات
الطيران التركيه تصريحا كانت قد منحته
لشركه فلايون ارمينيا لتسيير رحلات الى
اوروبا عبر المجال الجوي التركي
اعلنا رجل الاعمال الملياردير ايلون ماسك
عن خطه لمنصه تويتر تسمح لنا شيري الوسائل
الاعلاميه بتقاضي بدل من المستخدمين على
اساس قراءه كل مقاله على حده وبنقره واحده
وقال ماسك ان الخطه ستمكن المستخدمين
الذين لم يشتركوا شهريا بدفع بدل اعلى
مقابل قراءه كل ما قال بشكل عابر وان
الامر سيشكل مكسب رئيسيا للمؤسسات
الاعلاميه والجمهور
ضرب اعصار قوي منطقه بولايه فلوريدا
الامريكيه بحسب ما اعلنت هيئه الارصاد
الجويه الوطنيه في البلاد وادى الطقس
القاسي الى قلب السيارات وتحطيم النوافذ
والاشجار اوضحت السلطات انه لم يتم
الابلاغ عن وقوع اي اصابات لكنها طلبت من
السكان الحد من نشاطهم الخارجي والابتعاد
عن خطوط الكهرباء المتساقطه خاصه مع
توقعات ترجح ان اعصارا او اثنين سيتبعان
هذه العاصفه
هذه الساعه الاخباريه والتي خصصنا معظمها
للحديث عن الشان
السوداني
وتداعياته ايضا انتهت الساعه القادمه
سنتابع معكم فيها التغطيه المشهد السوداني
مع الزميل طالب كنعاني اليك طال
ب لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات